pour toi les pistes des épices la
période des fêtes c'est ce que la classe
et la cannelle pour noël incontournable
pour moi c'est la vraie car elle
reconnaît la salle aussi
60 ans c'est le moment le plus
merveilleux pour les épices pourquoi pas
c'est la tradition
biscuits tourtière pâtés à la viande
creton compte ils en commun les épices
on dirait que les épices sont venus
vraiment donner une odeur de un peu de
rêve je pense
surtout c'est là le lien avec le
patrimoine culinaire je pense qu'il
reste avec ces épaisseurs puis c'est le
moment on se rappelle les mémoires qui
sont chaleureuses avec des épices qui
sont chaleureux alors dans les épices
qu'on appellerait classiques du temps
des fêtes qui sont faits des épices
classique de la route des épices sont
les épices d'abord aromatiques très
parfumée il ya évidemment la casse et la
cannelle qui sont les reines de noël
mieux le gingembre ou six qui fait
partie beaucoup
le gingembre par l'immigration allemande
par la découverte des marchés de noël
allemand en trombe
la muscade et le macis bien sûr sauce
est hyper hyper classe et où les bègues
de noël sans massive ça existe pas
le macis et l' enveloppe de la muscade
qui elle est la garniture classique du
fameux lait de poule la cardamone
surtout dans les pays nordiques - chez
nous mais dans les pays nordiques on
s'en sert beaucoup et il ya la nuit
étoiles qui est un petit peu un nouveau
arriver parce qu'on aime bien la forme
de l'étoile étoiles ces symboles de noël
alors on a même beaucoup dans les plats
pour faire et c'est délicieux aussi le
fabuleux 4e prix ce qui est une épice
qui a le parfum de la cannelle de du
gingembre et de muscade tout ensemble et
du poivre dans une épice et le clou du
spectacle est le clou de girofle bien
sûr bien ce qui est partie intégrante de
toutes ces épices lac dont le qui fait
partie des serveurs du katri peut
justement déjà les romains dans
l'antiquité comme hershey par le biais
de ce qu'on peut appeler l'ancienne
route de la soie est pendant l'hiver on
mange ce qui a été récolté mais plus on
avance pendant l'hiver avant les
prochaines récoltes donc la saveur
commencé à diminuer des fois c'est un
peu fades ou presque pas consommables
alors faut masquer sont un peu lents les
pistes deviennent très très intéressant
le problème c'est que ça coûte
terriblement cher alors les gens qui ont
les moyens d'acheter des épices par le
commerce des épices sont des gens très
fortunés des rois des membres de la
noblesse qui vont justement vouloir
étaler la richesse quand ça va se
démocratiser avec l' empire britannique
le spa est beaucoup plus accessible
regardez du bois de métal je n'ai vu
chez ma mère et ma grand-mère de ces
petites boîtes là on va hériter des
recettes en faible de l'europe on va
éventuellement est très très influencé
par la cuisine britannique
les plus anciennes traces qu'on ne
comprend plus un peu d'épaisseur mentaux
deuxièmement peut-être troisième
millénaire avant notre ère en chine où
il faisait déjà ces espèces de gâteau
très succès parce que ça se conserver
mieux et plus longtemps aussi l'idée de
faire une maison succubus aviez fait les
allemands
[Musique]
et un débat à savoir est ce que la
maison d'un des plus allemande
influencer le conte d'hansel et gretel
des frères grimm ou est ce que les
frères grimm avec leur interprétation
des hommes seuls et gretel ont
popularisé la maison en pain d'épicés en
allemagne l'histoire
le vin chaud que l'on boit dans nos
marchés de noël est une tradition assez
récente chez nous et pourtant cette
coutume remonte aux roms les romains qui
faisait du vin très peu alcoolisé le
goûter moyens donc que par le commerce
des épices avait commencé à mélanger
justement la cannelle en particules
clous de girofle dans le vin on boit on
fait juste chauffeurs et des fines
herbes donc ça masque et gérer le groupe
un peu étrange d'une fermentation
quitterait pas optimale mais c'est comme
ça que dans les pays germaniques on ne
garder que cette tradition romaine
l'aigle inévitablement si neige et que
c'est l'hiver et que ça où les gens ont
cette envie d'aller goûter le vin chaud
épicé
[Musique]
le vin chaud savait qu on fait cuire
légèrement avec du sucre et des épices
il encore mais aussi les épices
classiques qui sont qu on voit pas mal
la salle et les proportions varient au
mais aussi du poivre ça c'est très
important et on mais aussi des écorces
d'agrumes alors souvent avec des écorces
d'orange parce que l'orangé ou 6 13 ceci
avec noël
et on fait chauffer à peine ont fait
tiédir on laisse reposer toutes les
épices infuse pour les ep soit entière
passée et pisan pour devoir enlever tout
gommé désagréable donc vraiment des
épices entières bien bien ce tamisée et
puis moi j'ai mon épée secret pour le
vin chaud qui la réglisse
vont s'infuser comme les bâtons de
cannelle le clou de girofle europe ils
vont fuser
dans nos traditions les épices du temps
des fêtes sont surtout associé à des
plats de viande mais pour l'uni il n'y a
pas de raison d'être en reste si on est
végétarien ou végétalien
je les ai appelés les boulettes magique
simplement parce que j'utilise un exempt
qui est la levure alimentaire qui pour
moi est vraiment un savoir une mamie
super concentré donc ça me permettra
d'aller chercher un petit goût de
revenez-y mais la base de ces boulettes
l'heure ce sont des graines de tournesol
des haricots noirs donc on va aller
chercher la manne belle texture et j'ai
mis des pistes traditionnelles aussi
j'ai de la cannelle du clous de girofle
et de la mousse campe est aussi un peu
de sarriette et de sauge
pour plus de saveur l'uni fait d'abord
sauté oignons ail et graines de
tournesol avant d'ajouter les épices la
levure alimentaire et les haricots noirs
j'ai ici des ingrédients et qui depuis
cherche un peu de savoir sirop d'érable
sauce soya ou tamari puis un petit peu
de vinaigre de cidre
ont réduit la préparation en purée
grossière et on ajoute de la chapelure
question d'avoir une belle texture pour
façonner de belles boulettes j'aime ça
composer une belle à cette
traditionnelle donc des patates pilées
des arts couvert on va avoir un petit
compact de canneberges aussi que moi
j'aime ça les servir avec une sauce à
son gré vie
[Musique]
quand goûter bah oui
c'est très bon il ya eu pas de
ça marche
tout le temps des fêtes c'est là qu'on
voit que justement en allant chercher
les épices c'est là qu'on est capable de
se replonger exactement les mêmes
savoirs moi je trouve le temps n'efface
pas une belle occasion de faire
découvrir des plots végétaline comme ça
[Musique]
c'est le premier que j'aime voyons donc
cherché ma merci ouais mais je parle
la différence c'est l'épaisseur des
défauts ce que j'aime c'est qu'un petit
morceau de puisque dans la bouche tu
pues la croquer alors là ça coûtait un
autre parfum qu'ont certains pour
fonction prend pas le grand vin bon vin
conseillé de préférer quelque chose
qu'on mettrait dans une casserole
quelque chose qu'on prendrait pendant
qu'on fait la cuisine mais pour quelque
chose qu'on parlera du rôle sous peine
de prison
vraiment beau mélange de personnes dans
ces épisodes sont partis du commerce
mondial depuis des milliers d'années et
on s'en sert dans toutes les cuisines du
monde parce qu'elles sont si
merveilleuse et si aromatiques et elle
change notre cuisine à noël et où le
reste de l'année aux
600 ex ante et mon temps des fêtes
[Musique]
et